we have some really big news today in
regards of phase four movies that could
be coming to the MCU how's it going
everyone it's Warren and I'm not talking
about the movies that we know are going
to be coming like Black Widow Doctor
Strange - black panther - I'm talking
about the Dark Avengers Young Avengers
and an Iron Heart movie these are
obviously huge movies that Marvel could
be planning for the future of the MCU so
I'll break down all the latest news
about these films in this video quick
reminder if you would like a chance to
win an Iron Man helmet a Captain America
shield and Infinity Gauntlet or another
Marvel Legends item be sure to subscribe
to my channel I'm picking three winners
from my giveaway at four hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so yesterday
comicbook.com
noticed that the URLs facebook.com slash
black widow and facebook.com slash
Marvel's Eternals both send the users
that go to the website two pages that
are set to private if you're on your
desktop computer and you take these URLs
type them in and go to the website
you'll find that the browser says
content isn't available which to be
clear is not the same as a 404 message
that simply states that the page or
website does not exist
so these websites do exist and are just
set on private but with San Diego
comic-con coming up in just a week
they're probably about to launch them
now of course this makes sense that
these movies would have their own
Facebook page but like I said today's
video is not about the black widow movie
or the Eternals movie these Facebook
pages are most likely official and we'll
go live during San Diego comic-con with
the announcement of Black Widow and the
Eternals however it has been discovered
that there are a few other Facebook
pages there is facebook.com slash Dark
Avengers facebook.com slash Young
Avengers official and facebook.com slash
Marvel's ironheart
so obviously this raises the huge
question is Marvel getting these
Facebook pages ready for upcoming movies
in the MCU if this is true that means we
will be getting a Dark Avengers movie a
young Avengers movie and an Iron Heart
movie now these movies have been rumored
to be in the works at Marvel Studios for
some time now especially after avengers
endgame and especially after a comment
that Robert Downey jr. has made recently
Robert Downey jr. at
in Chicago publicly stated that
ironheart should be in the MCU and also
Kevin Feige said that representation is
going to be a big part of the MCU moving
forward and if that is true then
ironheart is kind of a no-brainer to
introduce and after avengers endgame the
Young Avengers were set up really really
well to have their own film going
forward they set up Harley keiner to be
the next Iron Man at the end of Avengers
in game and of course Harley Kiner was
the little genius boy from Iron Man 3
Cassie Lang the daughter of Scott Lang
aka ant-man was set up to be stature at
the end of Avengers in game then of
course you have Hawkeye's daughter Lyla
who could be the next Hawkeye in the
Young Avengers and of course we have
little Morgan Stark who is a little bit
younger than everybody else but they
could set her up to become a man or an
iron heart or a iron lad version in the
MCU and then you have the Dark Avengers
which is something that people have been
talking about for a very long time now
even before Avengers and game came out
but now that Avengers in game is out it
is set up perfectly for a dark Avenger
story arc the state that the world was
left in after Thanos snapped and now the
state that the world is in after Iron
Man is gone and the mid-credits scene
for Spider Man far from home sets it up
as well and if a Dark Avengers movie is
being set up that means that Norman
Osborn will be entering the MCU pretty
soon this could also be the perfect way
to introduce Wolverine into the MCU by
introducing him in the Dark Avengers and
we could also get other characters that
fans have been waiting a long time to
see such as century so this is
definitely really exciting news if
Marvel is planning on introducing the
Dark Avengers The Young Avengers and
Iron Heart in the MCU we know that
Marvel has to outperform the last 10
years that it did and certainly
introducing the Dark Avengers The Young
Avengers and Iron Heart could definitely
do the trick but let me know what you
think about this let me know how excited
you would be if these movies came to the
MCU comment with your thoughts down
below and of course comment with your
favorite superhero or villain liked this
video and subscribe to my channel to
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof